I don't know
[Music]
whoa the mascara dripping down Hannah
Browns face the most emotional season
premiere ever I think on The Bachelor
last night what do you think I mean some
say emotional I would say the most
dramatic ever you know what Peter let's
that let's relive a bit more of your
trial all right I don't know what I was
doing I don't know
[Music]
alright Peter I have to grill you now
now chris is here I don't know if he can
protect you I'm out of this we have to
ask you about the mascara running down
Hannah Browns please or did you think
that that discussion would get as
emotional as it did absolutely not AB
that that wasn't even supposed to happen
that whole discussion that was so she I
knew that she the only thing I knew
about that date was that she was posting
it and yeah I was taking a chance that
could have been awkward at well
obviously was but she we were actually
supposed to have a date and it was
supposed to be the talk and they were
gonna have an audience come in and then
I heard that you know she was having a
tough time I went to go check on her and
then that whole discussion transpired
and you guys saw what happened but that
was never planned that was just that was
all real so you were surprised yeah no
Hannah was supposed to just kind of it
was supposed to be fun and we're just
let's bring her back and it'll kind of
shock everybody but you let's just send
Peter on his way and then it obviously
dissolved into what I would say was one
of the most riveting raw conversations
we've had in a long time you said that
you wished that Hannah had asked you out
during her finale instead of Tyler
Cameron and you said I wish that things
had worked out between us so how do you
go into a season of The Bachelor saying
that you wish things had worked out with
Hannah I yeah I I said that and I meant
it and I was obviously hurt when it that
didn't happen but I did my best to try
to you know move on and put that behind
me and when I was offered the
opportunity to be the bachelor I was
obviously so stoked for it and I took it
because I truly felt like I was ready
and I had moved on as much as I could
and I wasn't gonna let that be a
distraction moving forward what you saw
there was just feelings kind of
resurfacing and it was real and I was I
felt obviously horrible doing that to
the women that were there on the date
and just kind of out of respect for them
but I had to be true to myself and and I
was and everything I said I meant and
you know what is so what if she had
asked you out it's weird to say but it's
the weirdest a I if she would have I
would have said yes and I probably
Ashley who knows would you in Hannah be
together right now
I mean you never know the world may
never know now you know it's it is what
it is but that didn't happen
and you guys will see what happens you
know in the next episode with us with
that conversation where our relationship
maybe goes for the rest of the season
but can't live in the past it is what it
is
and I have no hard feelings for her I
know she was always following her heart
and doing the best she could and you
know I'm okay with that so what are you
thinking as you're watching this play
out did you think Hannah was about to
join his season as a contestant well I
don't know I'll answer that with a
question of do you agree it was a
conversation that needed to be had
absolutely clearly it was there was
something between you two that needed to
be resolved
absolutely yeah I mean the last time I
had seen her was other than the first
night was a fr you know on stage there
and it was great to talk to her but that
was really the first kind of raw
conversation just to kind of get that
possibly closure who knows he'll see
what happens but well Hannah justified
her asking Tyler out saying Tyler was
reaching out to her what did that mean
did that mean Tyler's DMing Hannah
texting with Hannah and had you stayed
silent yeah honestly I had not messaged
her at all there was zero communication
between the two of us you know there's
just that's just what I decided to do
and you know when I wanted to have
obviously an authentic talk with her on
stage there a senior I knew was gonna be
tough but that's what we did and there
was no communication so when you're
sitting there and Hannah's dripping in
tears and you're having these feelings
you looked like you were about to cry at
some points did you think about walking
away from the whole thing yeah yeah I
honestly uh you guys will see what's
said but I definitely considered in that
moment I know that sounds absolutely
crazy and insane but again I told
everyone and I don't think they ever
expected me to kind of display it to
that magnitude but I told everyone from
the very beginning I was gonna be raw be
myself you know do what I had to do and
in that moment
yeah good nobody knows how hard it is to
be the bachelor/bachelorette until
you're actually in those shoes
no and we always say it's gonna be an
emotional ride but I'm guessing you
never real
how this will strip you down oh my god
had no idea I think it was the most
beautiful experience of my life but the
absolute hardest in so many different
ways are you telling me that next week
we're going to see you say I might want
to walk away from being The Bachelor you
ok producer what's going through your
mind as you guys are in the control room
me thinking uh are we about to lose our
show you have to understand like yes I
keep saying but I was being true to
myself I it's and this is that's why I
don't feel that bad about it I didn't
necessarily have insane relationships at
that point aliens hadn't really formed
it was so early on so that's I get
myself kind of a Hall Pass in that
regard of why I allowed myself to feel
what I felt because I knew I had an
amazing group but I was just getting to
know them well you're comparing apples
and oranges you have a relationship with
Hannah at this point yeah you have
something that's clearly lingering one
of the most difficult things about the
bachelor and bachelorette is when the
show is over
typically the relationship will move on
the people that are broken up with you
really don't get that closure you see
him at AFR and you don't get that talk
so this was that talk that kind of
needed to have absolutely needed that
were you in love with Hannah during what
we saw last night yes
yeah I mean I am like alive yeah so I
when you started the show you were still
in love with her I thought I was in a
really good spot I promise you I did I
would not have done this I swear to God
if I didn't think I was ready to
absolutely move on but I always said it
I mean I remember saying it at AFR she's
always gonna hold a special place in my
heart it was a very amazing relationship
that we had and I don't know if you
completely ever lose that for someone a
hundred percent and I think you guys saw
yeah a lot of that resurfaced and it was
just it was very real and this is why
when people say why was Peter the
bachelor this is why what you see is
what you get he's a hundred percent raw
honest and and if you think this was
dramatic just wait till you see where
the season goes well have you and Hannah
talked did you text at all last night as
this episode was playing yeah just like
really good support and she's been
amazing
you know she's a huge fan of mine I'm a
huge fan of hers and I always will be
well she said something on Instagram or
Twitter she says something on social
media like enjoy the ride
she made it sound like you guys are not
together I just don't know if she may
enjoy the ride to her the guy it depends
on what you mean by ride also may be the
dirtiest premiere we've ever had last
night
so myself all right well what about
Hannah being the Bachelorette again this
is something fans are calling for how
would you feel about it okay so let's
pretend that yeah we're actually done I
am I would want she's yeah an amazing
girl and unfortunately everyone saw you
know what happened with her relationship
and that's unfortunate for everyone
involved she deserves it more than
anyone and is that a real possibility
Chris Harrison
I have no idea all right all options are
open
we'll see what about donation thanks
let's see what you think
have you talked to Tyler about last
night after his name got brought up I've
not talked to him specifically about
that we chatted in the earlier on in the
day and he just wished me good luck with
everything and with it all starting and
he's been awesome where it is he was
working on his abs all right so let's
talk about some of the standout ladies
from the premiere as you mentioned
Hannah always holding a special place in
your heart you gave Hannah and
first impression rose and Peter you said
and I quote I have room for two hands
and I didn't know how to feel about that
I feel like I said that's me I think
your intentions were good but I mean
really when I'm looking back on it it
was almost like you were kind of
subconsciously saying you did still have
these feelings for Hannah Brown but
maybe you could bring another Hannah in
okay yeah I can see how you get that
from that but honestly just cuz when she
said her name I loved it and then she
made that comment like of course they
have okay you're just being a little
part of the thought yeah I also get the
thing of like well can i really date
somebody right away with the same name
could you think it was Hannah an you
know my name just reducers actually give
her that they said maybe go in with your
I'd take that on them okay so let's talk
about some of your standout leaves I got
a couple pictures here for our lady
speed around Madison Madison Madison
gets a huge first one-on-one meeting
your parents off the bat does that give
her a big emotional advantage going
forward she met your whole family and
they seemed to love her yeah that I
lucked out with that date like no other
cuz that could have realistically been
really kind of awkward and uncomfortable
date that's a big thing introducing you
know the person you're dating to your
family in the first date but she
absolutely knocked out of the park
killed it to me that felt like a date
episode 7 yeah never had a family on the
premiere like that before it does you
live locally here's the issue and I
blame Peter and I blame his amazing
family is that normally wouldn't have
been such a big deal except for Peters
parents are incredible we do the renewal
of the vows and then it ended up in the
concert and it really in and then the
connection with Madison it really did
feel like wow is the show over yeah it
really was it was a beautiful day yeah
so is the show over with Madison I was
flying really high after that date and
she definitely you know got off to a
really good lead and you're so strong in
that lead I mean I think when you start
strong it's big Hannah an hour different
Hannah
we went from Hannah be to Hannah a
and so she gets the first impression
rose does and was that weird for you
were you thinking am I gonna potentially
end up with someone named Hannah at the
end of all this I I really wasn't
thinking about that I just she stuck out
to me so much is I know some people have
they have their opinions but I love the
boldness I loved her being so
intentional and showing me exactly why
she was there and I think it's important
to note that she she's the sweetest
person in the world right she was doing
it the right way she wasn't being mean
about it or just necessarily
disrespectful to any other women she's
the sweetest person and it worked and I
appreciate it is a girl that's gonna
find herself in the middle of a lot oh
she's sweet but she's sweet but the
faces trouble seems to find her no it
does there are some gates that ensue do
you jump over any of them I can't do any
more well fans were critiquing her a
little bit last night sounds like you're
defending her yeah I am I mean I I said
I gave her the first impression rose for
a reason and she made a huge impression
and I loved it that always does put a
target on people's back I get Diane
Hannah named Hannah Madison from Alabama
I know I think you have a type or you
were in some kind of Stockholm Syndrome
and I don't know I don't know I mean was
Hannah Brown on your mind night one no I
thought she got there no she really
wasn't we had a brief talk before
everyone showed up and I really you know
I was ready to fully move on officially
and until she came out of that limo I
wasn't thinking about her um did you
discuss with Hannah Anna night one that
she also currently lived at home did
that connect you to at all you know I
don't think that actually came up that
first night we definitely talked a lot
about her relationship with her family
which is huge for me but we didn't
actually talk about her living at home
what's it like going from living at home
with your parents to suddenly being away
traveling for the show like did you miss
mom and dad of course I miss though yeah
but they it was cool you guys let's see
like they come on a lot and I and I get
to talk to they're only a mile away from
the mansion they weren't too far at all
I literally am literally a mile you
still live at home right now yeah and
we'll be moving out yes
either way yes because you ended up with
someone either way yes actually
moving into my place we do you run into
each other at the gym what we do we run
into jazz mom now it's great all right
Chris ten years ago at the movie theater
was the very first time I remember that
he doesn't member but I'm far too big to
remember that were you thinking in that
moment I'm gonna be in that mansion with
him one day I had no idea no idea that's
very surreal for me it's pretty good
your mom seems very proud she posted a
childhood photo of you and said then the
little boy who grew up to be the
bachelor yeah did your parents ever
think this really could happen for you
was this discussed in your house I mean
Miami I will say my mom is the reason I
ever I went in for an audition when I
was like 22 a long time ago for the
first time for the match but never heard
anything but she's the reason I ever
kind of started this so her oh yeah
she's been a fan chef interesting - it's
we've never done this before like having
Hannah come in from Alabama you know
about the mansion it's on TV he's lived
in the shadow of the mansion literally
his entire life he drives by it a
thousand times going to and from the
beach and in around our neighborhood
where we're already shooting so it's
really interesting to do it with a guy
who has actually grown up around the
mansion it's it's been a different thing
it was going to actually I realized the
other day I'm like Colton action wasn't
the first bachelor to hop the fence
because I remember when I was like 18 or
19 I tried hopping the fence to get on
the mansion that's called try not to
legally let's talk about Victoria F who
Chris Harrison you told us is the
villain she's not not the villain
trouble we'll find her as well I'll say
that will her and Hanna and butt heads
because it sounds like they both get in
the middle of some stuff I'm just
predicting I don't think the two of them
but I I'm I'm a big fan of Victoria you
were not a big fan of her intro line did
you forgot that she said it I know that
was so bad I felt horrible done that
that's the dirtiest intro we've ever had
on the show before I forgot that I don't
either
you know yeah there was there was the
Chris soules plow your field Kaitlyn
Bristowe fan yeah I think I remember a
Jake Pavelka landing strip this memory
your fellow pilot I feel like that we
did do an 11
it's subtle that's the thing usually
it's like ply your field okay it's kid
there was nothing subtle about this
that's really we also had a pussycat
joke last night was this dirtiest
premiere ever yes dirty yeah four times
I don't know how many times you could
have said four times so many I think I
was making out with people in the
driveway house so that wasn't my doing I
do Fitz
so you're dubbing it you're giving it
the title yeah oh yeah move over Bob
Guinea eat the pilot yeah it was it was
a lot so you didn't remember her you
didn't remember her sexy joke yeah that
surprised me because Peter I know that
you you consider yourself kind of a
private person but the windmill is a
huge part of who you've become to the
fans and I told everybody at home don't
drink four times every time they say
four times how much does sexual
chemistry how much does chemistry play a
part in how things go for you yeah it's
a huge part for me sexual chemistry is
very important in a relationship
obviously what's come out with the
windmill and just my history about that
it's it's the public knows but yeah it's
a good thing I'm not uncomfortable
talking about it you know how did mom
and dad feel about the windmills
prevalence in your premiere they there's
they're good sports about it they laugh
it off mom was proud by the way when we
were after the final rose of all the
people that should have been shocked
it wasn't mom she was pretty proud of
her lamb boy last one here Kelly
yeah lawyer you'd met her before yeah
here locally ran into her at a
restaurant for a wedding yep send a beam
at where we ended up having our group
date after was at a hotel in a hotel
lobby yes that's Kelly gonna make it far
with you guys having that history I mean
I for sure I can say going into this I'm
thinking is this some type of fate like
why did this happen and didn't know she
was actually gonna show up that first
night and she was the last one before
Hannah Brown showed up so I was a
pleasant surprise and well when things
are coming at you so fast that first
night to have chemistry with somebody
already we've got a little bit of a life
preserver and I felt comfortable I felt
I remember that conversation we went out
to the front step and it just felt so
good just because I kinda already knew
her we had spent you know like an hour
talking when I'd first met her the first
time and it just felt really comfortable
and easy and it was good chemistry you
got along well I predicted the women
will come after her
that you cut all the flight attendants
and your parents ended up together a
pilot and flight attendant you ruined
that possible sequel in the family I
know I honestly I felt I was so bad
about that I feel like I let my parents
down a little bit but hey I loved like
they were great girls and their entrance
several entrances are awesome but
alright I got a couple more questions
for you first I want to play a little
celebrity moment Charlize Theron she
posted about you what was your reaction
when you saw that Charlize Theron I was
shocked
I'm a huge fan of hers that was so cool
when she did that and I remember we were
in New York and I was walking with my
family cuz we're there for the New
Year's Eve thing and I see her billboard
I'm like boom I got a great response by
the way I'm an old response I
interviewed her at the Palm Springs
International Film Festival asked her
about it she got a little red in the
face let's take a look at what she had
to say okay I do have to ask you about a
different passion of yours that pilot
Pete Instagram Charlize whoops Rove you
to post about the bachelors is it your
love for the show or Peter Hausen no I
love this he's like half my age not that
that should matter but no he's great I'm
super excited I love the show I've
missed it and I'm just so glad that the
show premieres in the winter when it's
dark early cuz my kids don't know what
time I send them to bed but like 5:45 as
soon as it's dark he posted back with
one of your ads did he try to slide into
the DMS no I don't even know really what
a DMS let's be honest maybe he has I
don't I don't think so did you I did not
okay first of all straight not buying it
Charlize she knows what a DMA she
definitely does second of all oh you
know she knows what a DM is let's wait a
minute I'm not gonna lie I'm a little
jealous of Peter in this this point here
but Peter yeah
not saying how not [ __ ] not saying how
the show ends yes
would you stop everything if you could
have no you get a date with Charlize
Theron's I mean I wouldn't put anything
past me you saw what half with Hannah
brown so I'll leave it at that
oh wow Peter Peter all right well um if
you end up with someone I hope she's not
watching this
or maybe he's already with Charlize and
that's how the show ends you know I
looked I didn't think III think when I
checked you guys actually both were not
following each other on Instagram I did
a social because you can't be that
obvious
right yeah I think I need a father I
don't know if I'm fall under yet yeah
he's follow okay step one into sliding
into the DMZ right it would sound like
your idea but well step one is go to
stagecoach step two I mean these
questions you come up you know we've had
wells Adams has ended up with an actress
Tyler Cameron dated a supermodel
Jennifer Aniston also big fan she's
single okay what about what you got you
guys gonna get me in trouble like this
is all it's all good fun I just like the
joke I need to set that record straight
this is all but I will say I wasn't sure
who came up with the response I was
thinking maybe a producer was with you
at the time when you that response was
great that was really good no that was
cool Shirley's thanks for watching the
show that's our nation's big fan let's
talk about how things do end up because
you have said that this is oh you don't
know right
you said that this is going to be the
first ending in a while it will not be
spoiled that won't get out on some of
the blog's why did you say that why do
you feel that confidence there just the
reason the specific reason I was taking
to say it but that I feel like this is a
little bit unique of an ending it is a
unique ending for sure I couldn't I
couldn't have predicted this and there's
over that last week was the hardest week
of my entire life to tell you absolutely
part of my life we saw in the beginning
of the premiere even before we get into
it you tease to the ending and you say
we just found something out what did the
production team just find out you going
back to the the Hannah conversation and
being so riveting and being one of the
most gut-wrenching moments this season
will take you on a rollercoaster ride
like none other and right up until the
end when Peter and I sit down and have
to have a very tough heart-to-heart
actually a couple of them that final
week it really is unlike any season
we've ever had before and I'm not saying
that just to to kind of pump the season
up it's just when you have a bachelor
like Peter it's just it's a very raw
emotional ride and the way this ends
we'll see coming I can say that because
we didn't see it coming yeah you didn't
the crew at the production side was
surprised about things I'm saying Peter
and I didn't decide the point
Peter and I going through this together
had no idea this was happening in how
this was going to all come to an end so
it's uh it's riveting and it really is
breathtaking and it'll break your heart
there are some people speculating online
that will also get this big huge finale
that you'll get engaged in the finale
what do you say to those predictions has
that ever happen engaged in the live
finale I know that's AFR it's a good
guys I I mean that's whatever happened
it's trying to think testing is now you
guys you don't you can't see this coming
for a while so alright we see you're
talking about gut wrenching we see a
clip of your mother Peter crying and
saying you bring her mom cries what it's
like watching oh it's it's painful to
see does that moment happen before or
after this big reveal
that's it's in the last week all that
that last week is insane
sounds like your mom gets really
attached to somebody do you think yeah
from that who's nominated for a Golden
Globe
by the way Bob yeah that's the thing is
again Peter so close to his parents or
his parents play a big part in this as
well and their emotion and all that is
is captured you're gonna see it you're
gonna see it all play out and it really
is it'll take your breath away are you
engaged right now see what happens we
talked about this I gotta tell you
Madison and Hannah Ann you seem to have
a strong connection with Madison you
really seem to have a strong connection
with Kelly one thing I kept noticing
about Hannah Ana's you kept saying her
name over and over again
and look I really like this guy so I'm
always like well Chris Harrison are
granted dinner you kept saying Hannah
Ann Thank You Hannah Ann and that really
stuck out to me Peter yeah yeah I like
that you caught on to that now she's an
absolute sweetheart and you guys are
gonna fall in love with her like no
other the Ben she's gonna get into some
stuff yeah we never sure about that a
lot of Hannah's does your dad cry uh I
think you already saw him cry he cried
on
yeah first one there is no shortage of
emotion at all this entire he thinks he
make he thinks he might cry more than
any other bachelor in the history of the
show
oh yeah I probably yeah you blow mez
nickel way colton got a little weepy
around some Cassie stuff and all that
but huh like it yeah my last question in
all this look you guys have delivered so
much on the show and I know the premiere
ratings huge Colton's ending was insane
Hannah's ending was insane how does
Peter's ending stack up to what we've
seen the past few seasons it's not
comparable because it's completely
unlike those stories the way it unfolds
even Colton and Hannah's seasons were
completely different this will stand
alone and and be epic for a completely
different reason it's not for an
athletic event and it's not for the
topsy-turvy twists and turns that was
Hannah his is more of an emotional ride
and roller coaster at the end and how
you doing now yeah
I'm doing good I really am I'm happy you
don't look well I don't say that not
this it's crazy like just reliving this
now and watching that first episode and
it's all it's coming back now
and so the fuels are obviously coming
back and it was the most beautiful thing
though the most beautiful experience my
life and I'm excited for I talked to him
last night inside baseball we were
texting back and forth and I told him
once the show starts mm-hmm it really
does change again cuz you've lived
through this yeah but who gets to and
who has to sit back and watch everything
unfold the most raw brutal moments of
your love life that's it's not easy to
do so we've tried to prepare him for
that yeah it's not but again that's also
there's a good side of that and that's
one of the reasons I was so excited to
do the bachelor it was to have that
opportunity to have my story you know
kind of forever and recorded and
documented and no luck again are you in
a relationship right now
Oh unfortunately that's all the time we
have here on entertainment tonight we'll
be right back
[Laughter]
[Music]